hello I am in a hotel right now because
I'm actually at a con and that kinetic
on and no the guests have arrived yet
they got me a day really so it's just
like okay well bring my work with me
watched a bunch of avatars so next
couple you might see in this hotel room
so okay its next episode here we got the
the avatar and the Fire Lord and boy
nice to finally see what he vanished
means in the opening it's like when we
needed him the most he vanished and what
yeah so it is nice to finally get
information on that ah another good
again sir showing how similar Zuko and
Aang are how they are in many respects
not as much opposites as much as
parallel very similar we see this
backstory kind of similar of two people
that seem like they're on the opposite
ends of the coin but they're also sort
of living parallel lives and one made a
choice to finally pretty much let go of
the other uh well really they both did
didn't they
because the the avatar decides no you've
gone too far I'm gonna never look back
on you and then oh the the Fire Lord he
actually comes back sees he's in trouble
starts to help and then decides to let
him die pretty much and yeah it's nice
to know the story I like stories about
either close friends or siblings that uh
the fall apart you know they used to be
best friends and now what has happened I
I don't know why I like those um again
it's fascinating to see if they take the
route oh hey you can come back or no you
made your choice you have to live with
it so uh so I liked all that as her
follows I don't say the formula but it
definitely follows the pattern that we
see often in these stories where one
does have a choice and finally if that
choice won't decide their outcome and
who they are I thought I found it very
fascinating how he was uh the Fire Lord
after laying the avatar died immediately
went into trying to
the other one and searching for years
and years when I got the power he wiped
out the the airbenders and but even then
he just had a feeling like he didn't he
didn't get him and I like that but that
was very uh very interesting just sing
about it just hunting down your friend
even like the reincarnation your friend
just a Justin settling strange but on
top of that we have we have Mako's Makos
Markos whatever the replaces replacement
voice which is fine I am pretty positive
now hearing the voices that all the
voices I heard a Mako in the past with
the exception maybe one or two subtle
lines or words here there was all Mako
because this voice does not sound like
what I thought could possibly be the
replacement voice before which I find
really interesting because hearing Makos
voice through those first two seasons
now knowing it must be him unless they
got replacement actor and then got
another replacement actor but I don't
think that was the case I heard that
wasn't the case uh it's very fascinating
because his voice at times would be very
very clear in another times it is a ASPI
and I actually sorta knew him more with
the very raspy voice hearing the clear
voice I almost not like oh did they get
another person for this but knowing it
was him is very interesting um and I
that this replacement voice is fine um
like I guess I mean they had to get
somebody else to fill in the shoes and
he doesn't great at first I was like oh
that's a replacement voice so to that
extent I guess it was a touch
distracting but no matter what you can't
get around that unless you know for a
fact that unless it's like pitch perfect
which nobody's voice is going to be
exactly pitch perfect to the other
except my brother and I and that is
freaky and we apologize for that so
bottom line you got this good episode
give some good backstory obviously the
uncle's building up more that Zuko does
have more
or even though he thinks his journey is
over he say no you do actually have a
part you can still play in this and you
can truly redeem yourself like it's
basically redeeming himself twice one
for the fire nation well that didn't
work he still feels like now he's
gonna redeem himself for himself which
he uncle was saying that's like he was
what I've been doing to begin with so I
like that the uncle is talking to him
again I don't know if I needed something
to push him to do it because that was
the one thing I was like wait why is he
suddenly talking to him again why is he
suddenly saying hey you have this chance
you have when he was given the silent
treatment for so long uh but I'm not
that bothered I think the reason is that
why do people give the silent treatment
to begin with because well it's one of
two reasons one either the person giving
the silent treatment is very emotional
and just can't talk to them or they're
doing it because they know the other
person needs that they need and I think
that's what it was because Zuko was
coming saying uncle I'm confused please
I don't know what to do I feel terrible
I I can't get this right and he has to
know that he really has gone too far to
a point where he won't even respond but
and he has to sit with himself he has to
sit with his thoughts and he has to
really analyze what is going on and what
does he want and what does he need and I
think before where the uncle did give
him a little bit of space he still
followed we they met up again in the
chase episode and there's a very
possible chance maybe that wasn't the
right thing to do and I think the uncle
might have realized that so I think he
knows here that he wants to give him a
little bit more distance and he has to
be alone with his pain because he made a
really tough bad choice that he has to
live with it for a bit
if the uncle came back with well here's
what you have to do you have to do this
this and this he would have felt it as
much he would have realized hey this he
has to realize this could be forever he
could be feeling this forever
and now he might have a way out the
uncle will once again come back and give
advice but he had to feel for a while
that there will be no way out of this I
have made this choice I can never go
back on it now but the uncle does come
and say hey here's this chance so I
think I did like that if like I say at
first I wasn't sure but I I think that
holds up I think that's a very legit
choice on their part to have him start
all silent and then start speaking to
him again whether or not that was
intentional or just a transition into
the new mega voice I don't know but it
works and knowing this now that he
actually does come around to speaking
again and even with the story with the
the Firelord the avatar them not
speaking to each other for a long time
though that backfired in this case
hopefully it will not backfire I'm
guessing it's not gonna backfire um but
we'll see where that goes
so good solid episode good to know the
history could have used maybe one or two
more twists and turns at the end of the
connection to the bloodline the family
line is interesting though I do when I
heard it I went wait one I had to rewind
I'm like wait so Zucco's mother is
connected to the Zuko's father is
connected to the Great Fire Lord or the
great grandfather okay it's like I think
I got it now and it's it's good at first
I thought I misread it so bad that first
I said wait a minute
Aang and him are related and it's like
no no that's not it it's the right the
mother is the mother's relatives is the
avatar and the father's relatives are
Fire Lord so it which is interesting
again I mean uh the uncle is trying to
say this blood is in you you have a
chance to turn around which I never know
about that it's like well it's in your
blood because you have the blood it's or
that minute glorion thing it's like I
don't know but maybe it's just what Zuko
needs to hear to get his head back in
the game and realize what it really
needs to do so whether or not you buy
that or not you know whatever genes
being passed on
and so forth I mean it could be maybe
not but it's what Zuko needs to hear so
yeah I'm interested even X episode goes
I'll see you at that one